aber wie sehr das aus am ende können wir
uns vorstellen tatsächlich dieser ich
muss nochmal darauf zurückkommen dieses
horror szenario des angriffs passiert
tatsächlich wie würde wladimir putin
dann die ukraine unter kontrolle halten
all das was ich dort erlebe ist eine
zivilgesellschaft die dann
möglicherweise in einem partisanenkrieg
gehen würde ich weiß nicht oder glauben
sie dass wladimir putin irland unter
kontrolle halten könnte wir sind bereit
für unsere land für die heimat zu
kämpfen weil wir viel zu oft in der
geschichte und zwar nicht nur in den
letzten jahrzehnten sondern auch hinter
ihr runter zurück unserer staatlichkeit
verlieren mussten deswegen stellt für
uns alles auf dem spiel gleichzeitig
haben wir auch in der bild zeitung
gelesen diese szenarien dass man
internierungslager schon heute
vorbereitet dass man auch ein
machtwechsel vorbereitet und das heißt
dass man schon strategisch denkt dass
man nicht nur natürlich die truppen
jetzt schickte das werde natürlich auch
kein spaziergang für ihn weil wie sie
sagen die ukraine natürlich da sind und
sie werden kämpfen für für das land das
stellt nicht in frage er tritt ihn
halten sie das für möglich dass russland
tatsächlich die ukraine besetzen kann
und langfristig unter kontrolle halten
kann ich glaube das wäre ein sehr
blutige höhepunkt aber es ist nicht
ausgeschlossen dass er diesen irrtum
begeht
es gibt andere szenarien die sagen es
kommt zu partiellen besetzungen oder der
implementierung einer regierung die sich
sozusagen von den glatten da ist das ist
alles offen noch mal egal welche form
der militärischen intervention der stadt
findet es wird eine harte antwort aus
europa gemeinsam mit den usa an dieser
stelle geben und das ist dass der hinter
kabul dem jetzt scholz in nach moskau
ich will ihnen einmal zeigen was us
präsident joe biden gesagt hat zu der
frage was uns hier auf der ganzen welt
drohen könnte nämlich das ist ein
weltkrieg wenn amerikaner und russen
beginn aufeinander zu schießen diese
konkrete wanne und die dort
ausgesprochen wird lambsdorff haben sie
auch sorge naja als vertikales aus dem
zusammenhang gerissen da ging es darum
dass die frage gestellt wurde werden
amerikanische soldaten in die ukraine
verlegt angesichts der russischen
bedrohung da hat joe biden ganz klar
gesagt die ukraine ska nato mitglied und
wenn wir da amerikanische soldaten in
schickten dann könnte das zu einem
weltkrieg führen also insofern das zitat
ist so wie es da ist aus dem
zusammenhang gerissen ich glaube das was
jürgen trittin ihre angesagt ist genau
das was ganz am anfang gesagt haben du
rust hat drei große ehre zumal wenn es
meint mit der inversion da zurecht zu
kommen das eine ist eben wirklich ein
langer blutiger
widerstand aus der ukraine heraus die
ihre staatlichkeit bewahren will und
vergessen wir nicht so dominant putin im
russischen politischen systeme auch so
20 24 sind präsidentschaftswahlen wenn
es verlustreiche kämpfe gibt und die
komitees der soldatenmütter gründen sich
wieder von stoff bis wladiwostok und in
jeder stadt gibt es jährige wieder
ankommen und es gibt unmut und ärger in
der bevölkerung in politischen ärger das
ist nicht das ist eine das ist eine der
kalkulation von denen ich dem kreml nur
raten würde sie zu machen wir hören ja
die entschlossenheit der ukraine das
zweite ist der dax mit dem westen als
drittes die totale abhängigkeit
russlands von china das kann doch alles
nicht im russischen interesse ist wenn
das passieren sollte erhard haben sie
sorge dass putin das ist ja das was auch
immer aus der ukraine zu hören ist dass
das nur der anfang ist vitali klitschko
hat sich heute der bild am sonntag
geäußert und hat gesagt dass dann
möglicherweise als nächstes die
baltischen staaten dran sein und man
immer weiter vorrücken würde halten sie
das für möglich dass putin nicht nur
richtung ukraine spielt sondern sagt
okay dann will ich wirklich das gesamte
reich zurück haben ich habe bereits
darauf hingewiesen dass belarus immer
stärker auch unter der kontrolle
russlands kommt auch militärisch mit dem
hinweis auf die veränderung veränderung
der wähler russischen verfassung ich
habe auch den eindruck dass russische
truppen nicht nur an der
litauer an der ukrainischen grenze
stehen sondern eben auch richtung
polnischen litauischen grenze
stationiert waren möglicherweise auch
mit mittelfristigem langfristig
dauerhafte stationierung und wir wissen
dass russland immer wieder
vorträgt es müsse eine landverbindung
zum rio kaliningrad geben aber ich und
genau werden die profis aufgebaut ich
sage wehret den anfängen wir müssen wir
müssen vermeiden dass sie zum einmarsch
in der ukraine kommt und wenn es zum
einmarsch in der ukraine kommt müssen
wir dafür sorgen dass es der anfang vom
ende von der herrschaft von vladimir
putin ist und dazu ist eine starke
widerstandsfähige ukraine genauso
wichtig wie eine klare politische und
wirtschaftliche dallas ist mit den
baltischen staaten trittin ich habe auch
mal aus der ukraine gehört ja wer sagt
uns denn dass putin sozusagen im
innersten sagt mensch also die ehemalige
ddr die gehört auch zu meinem
einflussbereich ja sie können vieles
rein interpretieren und ganz viel
spekulieren ich glaube dass die hürde
ein nato staaten anzugreifen weil der
satz von beiden denen sie eben
eingespielt habe auch umgekehrt gilt
wenn russische soldaten angefangen auf
amerikanische oder britische deutsche in
litauen zu schießen dann ist dann
tatsächlich eine eskalation an dieser
stelle da die nicht im interesse
russlands sein kann ich finde wir
sollten auch mal versuchen die
dimensionen klar zu machen was putin
macht ist ein stück
brutalster
militärischer fast terroristische
herrschaft sicherung aber er tut das auf
der basis eines staates der über
atomwaffen verfügt aber ein
bruttosozialprodukt hat wie spanien das
durchschnittseinkommen des russischen
bürgers ist heute niedriger als das
eines chinesischen bürgers das ist die
situation auf der putin
vermeintlich auf der weltbühne spielt
und deswegen ist diese frage der
botschafter der gesagt hat eure
sanktionen interessieren mich nicht da
bin ich ganz bei hanhart da hat jemand
gesagt hat ja gar nicht wehgetan und
hielt sich dabei
angemeldet was macht das mit ihnen wenn
sie hören menschen nato-staaten die sind
ja geschützt sie haben das versucht
damals 2008 in die nato zu kommen und
jetzt heißt es ja gut ich können wir
leider nicht helfen ja das ist genau der
punkt herting gerade anspricht weil man
in der nato ist ist man geschützt und
und deswegen oder gerade deswegen ist
die gefahr eines möglichen einmarsches
im baltikum
aus unserer sicht sehr unwahrscheinlich
weil man natürlich dann mit den
amerikanern mit den deutschen mit den
briten zu tun haben wird und deswegen
wollen auch wer ukraine teil dieser
familie werden auch deswegen da wollen
auch wir beitreten diesen
verteidigungsbündnis und das ist ein
bündnis um die mitglieder zu verteidigen
und wir wollen dazu auch einen eigenen
beitrag leisten es ist nicht so dass man
sie an flüchten wollen wir haben gezeigt
wir sind bereit zu sterben wenn es sein
müsste für die eigene heimat und wir
sind bereit auch einen beitrag so leicht
haben wir sorge an die sorge dass die
amerikaner oder auch die europäer am
ende die ukraine opfern und sagen na gut
ukraine ist nicht teil der nato an
russland nicht weitergeht dann
also mein präsident hat gesagt wenn
deutschland jetzt in einer lage wie wir
uns befinden würde dann hätten wir auch
den deutschen geholfen das hat er vor
wenigen tagen gesagt und wir glauben
dass es die einen die einzige option
eigentlich die auf dem tisch bleibt dass
die ukraine teil dieser familie wird von
der nato und nicht wie heute in diesem
grauen zone weiterhin existieren müsste
weil das ist auch diese existenz dieser
zustand alleine wäre eine einladung für
putin immer wieder schwachstellen zu
suchen